Daily Mail has this when a marriage hits
a rocky patch couples find different
ways of bringing back the magic date
night or perhaps counseling for Jada
pinket Smith and her husband will it
took a public Scandal to reset the
relationship pinket now says in an
interview quote I nearly didn't even
attend the Oscars that year but I'm glad
I did I call it the holy slap now
because so many positive things came
from it she is of course referring to
the 2022 Oscars at which her husband had
been nominated and he slapped we know
about that
she says quote that moment of the S
hitting the fan is when you see where
you really are after all those years of
trying to figure out if I would leave
Will's side it took that slap for me to
see that I will never leave him who
knows where our relationship would be if
that hadn't happened so it's another
interview that Jada pcket Smith is doing
and in this interview she says that um
she's glad that the slap happened
because that's when she decided that
she's not going to leave Will Smith
because it was strengthening of their
relationship or something like like that
so first of all Jadis pet Smith just
will not stop talking she won't stop she
apparently subscribes to the uh to the
school of PR crisis management that says
when you're in a PR crisis just keep
talking which is the exact opposite of
what you're supposed to do in these
situations just but her idea is like
just say more and more
things and I guess the hope is that is
that you you'll you'll win the public
relations War by attrition or maybe the
idea is to say so many insane and
disgusting and repelling things that you
know nobody can keep track anymore so
I'm not sure what the strategy is but
but this woman will not stop and now she
says the slap was a great thing for
their marriage and it's when she decided
not to leave Will Smith except that she
did leave him so she she did leave him
so she decided not to leave him except
in the sense that she she actually did
leave like she left the house and moved
in somewhere
else and announced to the world that
they're not uh that they're not together
anymore so in that sense she left him
but in some other sense some
mystical ephemeral sense she didn't
leave him I I you know if that makes
sense which it
doesn't but the real takeaway here is
that is that she sees the slap as a
positive as holy it destroyed her her
husband's life and career like his
career is over because it and it's
probably never really gonna at least
it's never to come it's never going to
get back to what it
was it made him into a disgrace a
punchline like that is the thing that
people will remember Will Smith for
forever that is his legacy
now and she sees it as a
positive and why is that because she
obviously enjoys watching this man
debase himself as we know she takes a
great deal of pleasure in in Will
Smith's public
humiliation like it really is amazing
how evil this woman is she's like a
cartoon she's the kind of person who if
you if if she was a character in a
movie like it would take you you out of
the story because it it's she's too evil
you would say like it's not even
believable for most homeowners window
replacement is not something that
they've done before and for many it
isn't something that they want to do but
rather something they have to do if you
put off replacing windows in your home
because it's too expensive I have great
news you can now get a free inhome
window consultation and a free price
quote from Renewal by Anderson Renewal
by Anderson's signature service is
committed to giving you the best
customer experience possible through the
perfect combination of the best people
in the industry a superior process in
and an exclusive product right now
Renewal by Anderson is offering a free
inhome or virtual consultation on
durable quality affordable windows or
patio doors for $ Z down zero payments
and zero interest for a year text Walsh
to 200 300 for your free consultation to
save
$375 on every window and $750 on every
door these savings aren't going to last
long so be sure to check it out by
texting Walsh to 200 300 that's Walsh to
200 300 but she continues to be at least
a great cautionary Tale for young men
and that's why I always say anytime that
there's
a story about Jada pinket Smith now she
she is she's a
um she's a quite an extreme
case but to to a somewhat maybe a lesser
degree this is not uncommon in
relationships where you have one member
of the relationship who who
like enjoys the other person being
embarrassed and you there are plenty of
men who find themselves in relationship
relationships with women who are like
this and yet it happens in the reverse
too but just talking about the Jada
pinket Smith like there there are many
Jada pinket Smiths maybe not quite she's
the you know she's the ultimate super
villain but uh but there are many who
are kind of in her you know sort of in
that
vein and you could see you know you see
uh examples of it all the time like
we've all been around you know you're
around a couple
and maybe the wife or the girlfriend
brings something up supposedly in a
joking way but that's actually
embarrassing for the man and you could
tell that he's really embarrassed by
it you know and and yeah you can do that
in a way that's actually
joking you know and uh and you can't
take yourself too seriously in a
relationship and so you tease each other
or whatever that you know that can
happen even even in publicly in a way
that's obviously well-meaning
but um there are plenty of times when we
we've all seen this and it's very
awkward to be around it when you see a
man get kind of like cut down and
embarrassed by his wife or his
girlfriend and uh you could tell you
know Jada pinket Smith loves doing it
she loves to just embarrass this
man this is it's red flag you know if
you're with a you know men are always I
get questions from young men all the
time what should you be looking for in a
woman what you know there's a lot to be
looking for but when you talk about red
flags you're dating a woman if there's
like one
time even
once when she does or says
anything that is intended to
legitimately embarrass you even in a
small
way then get the hell
out just just get out immediately you
got a j to Pink and Smith on your hands
and it's not going to get better as Will
Smith uh unfortunately for him has
discovered thanks for checking out this
video if you'd like to listen to my full
podcast on the go you can check out the
Matt wall show on Apple podcast Spotify
or wherever you get your podcast